let's bring in Pat McAfee former all-pro
punter for the Colts and now radio host
he's done everything now what was your
rookie salary it was three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars I believe and I
got a forty-seven thousand dollar
signing bonus being picked 222 and I
spent every single dollar before my
second year yep what was your biggest
purchase so I bought a Cadillac Escalade
the day I was arrested because I didn't
fully understand what a signing bonus
but I thought that money was just gonna
come right into my bank account it turns
out it didn't show up like three months
almost got the car repo'd I had to go
into the bank was like a Google news
story that this was the money I was
going to get how are you by the way I'm
excellent man how are you it's always so
it's such an honor to come on the show
since I've been such a fan for so long
thanks for having me life is good how's
everything over there oh it's great no
complaints got a beautiful mancave we
got to get you in the mancave
it's it's great got beer on tap we got
you know the side of the field too for
kicking we got basketball hoop there we
got a nice little crib here I saw
whenever bleacher report made the big
move I think I watched it was either
McLovin or Paulie given at or behind the
scenes while you were cutting a promo
and that thing just looked absolutely
majestic over there well deserves
obviously and it'd be an honor to come
in there and slam some beers with the
boys what did you take away from last
night what should we take away I think
preseason the more this is what I
thought last night actually less guys
are playing in the preseason even more
so than in the past like nobody really
took preseason that serious but the
first couple games it was always the
time like let's get them one series
let's see how it goes let's get to
warm-up let's get the team routine down
so we can practice this so we don't look
like dummies whatever the regular season
comes but now it almost feels like
preseason is just becoming an extended
practice which I kind of respect I
assume that at some point
they're going to get rid of a preseason
game or two to kind of adjust the
scheduled either 17 or 18 games I assume
the next CBA there's going to be a lot
of talk about it I was happy for the
young guys going out and make some plays
that she/he character from the Browns
taking a punt back I didn't love that
for the brand but I loved it for the
guys story sleeping on the streets I
just think the preseason is becoming an
extended practiced in a chance to
showcase the draft guys and the young
guys and the for us for the Indianapolis
Post the city I live in we better hope
luck it's healthy because the often look
bad but Chad Kelly came out and made
some plays I just I enjoy the football
is back but I think every time I watch a
preseason game I just get a little bit
more excited for the regular season and
good football again what will get you a
cut in pre-season so you know while I
was watching Hard Knocks
with old Gruden in the Raiders over
there Napa Valley the thing that will
get you cutting preseason I'll bring it
for their first-round picks you can do
whatever you want you'll never get
caught for your first couple of years
but learning how to practice is a big
deal if you're like a fringe player and
a bubble player in a practice you're
taking guys down to the ground and
you're hitting people and you're risking
a lot of injury to people that are
important on your team like Jonathan
Abram was basically that is something
that can definitely get you cut because
you got to learn how to practice missing
meetings and being immature is something
it gets you cut but at the end of the
day it's all a numbers game and it's
kind of one of those things where guys
become casualties or roster casualties
where we need another safety so we got
to get rid of an offensive lineman and
you just kind of hope somewhere else
picks it up but it's all a numbers game
and it's also a big maturity game for a
lot of the young guys to kind of figure
out that this is a business down it's
not just a kids game anymore
he's Pat McAfee former all-pro punter I
think you told Rich Eisen recently that
you tried out for the Bears yeah I was
gonna go kick field goals for the Bears
and I mean I would have been a pretty
cool story I Chuck Pagano is their D
coordinator now he was the head coach
for the quotes for a longtime friend of
mine and they were obviously looking for
a kicker after the situation last year
with Cody parky who's a great kicker if
he gets the ball just like an inch to
the right
it happens but obviously the Chicago
Bears were seeking a kicker for their
team's storied franchise and they hired
a kicking consultant for their team who
was actually my kicking coach coming out
of college so it seemed as if all the
stars were aligning for potential
comeback for me to come kick field goals
I put it through an entire stress test
with their kickin coach the ball was
flying well I think I was gonna be the
first guy in the history of the league
that both punted and kicked successfully
in the NFL and I got on a plane and my
old ask me just started to swell up I
couldn't even get to the bathroom like I
know Dan it was like a moment between me
and my knee that was like my he
literally was talking to me like a man
we're not doing this again
let's just talking to microphones enjoy
our lives have some vitamins we're not
getting back into this the rigors of
kicking footballs again but I was all in
I was ready to do it full focus full
steam ahead and I think it would've been
a cool thing but now I get a chance to
follow in some dreams and focus on some
other cool stuff but it was a real
moment of closure for me whenever I
couldn't get up and go to the John at
about 32,000 feet sitting on a Southwest
flight but you look at these extra
points it feels like the kickers have
gotten better with field goal kicking
but not kicking extra points why is that
so I think whenever the field goal got
moved back to a 33 yard field goal the
initial thought was we're gonna find out
quickly that there are tears to kicking
in the NFL there's like the elite
kickers in the NFL the guys that are you
everybody knows amid oskowskis the
Tucker's the Venna Terry's the guys that
are at the top of their game for a long
long time then there's a lot of guys
that kind of get on this kicking terror
so where they kick for a team they get
cut they try to get hot somewhere and
they just kind of bounce around teams a
team and I think the extra point is
something that used to be a gimme
obviously used to walk on the field you
could hit a terrible ball and it would
go through but with 33 yards I mean
there's a chance for a little bit of a
messing I think it just shines a
spotlight on who's good who's worth a
lot of money who can win their team
games and also the guys that maybe
aren't there yet mentally or physically
so I think it's just one of those things
where you have to focus
33-yard kick you have to hit a good ball
you can't steal a point there anymore
and I think it just kind of puts a
little bit of a spotlight on the people
that aren't as great as the ones that
are at the top of the game got a
training camp story with no names
attached to it well I mean training camp
is in such a and I think it's starting
to come out more and more now and as we
live in this more woke society you never
hear retired players say he misses
training camp right I think it's
becoming more of a recognized thing the
training camp is not a good time for a
lot of people unless you have like four
kids under the age of five and you get a
chance to go stay at a dormitory away
from your kids you can sleep for a
little bit training camp is a tough one
and for me it wasn't obviously as
physically tough and for Venna Terry and
I it wasn't that physically tough so it
was always one of those things where we
just tried to keep it light we always
try to have a good time every single day
there was a fight on the field basically
if couple guys got into it I felt as if
it was my job in the locker room
afterwards to grade the fighting to give
goring as if I'm a judge in a UFC fight
it just to kind of calm that calm the
tension a little bit every single time a
rookie would have to get up there and
sting I saw it as if it was my job to
motivate them to do their best it was
just it was one of those things of
balancing not only morale but also egos
and just try to get the team through it
so whenever we hit the game day and the
regular season the whole team's running
but training camp is long for those guys
that have to bang their heads into each
other and for me and for most kickers
and punters around the league I'd assume
our job is just what let's keep these
people happy
it must hope not get beat up through
this thing while they are literally
grinding away and we're just sitting
over here chugging chocolate milk yeah I
look at the situation with the cold
Senor they're in Indianapolis with
Andrew Luck that it started out of
something small and then it sort of
staying with us a little bit and maybe
staying a little bit longer than we
thought with this calf injury how
concerned do you think we should be
about Andrew Luck's calf injury this is
a nightmare dance no no they don't they
don't tell me anything right the coats
refused to tell me anything I got good
friends in the F
like training room I got friends in the
equipment room I got friends that are
still on the team obviously finitary
still wearing his depends diapers and
kicking out there he's gonna be at my
wedding I mean I got I got good friends
in there but nobody will tell me
anything they're keeping this one pretty
tight-lipped and whenever I saw him
first sitting out some practices and
OTAs or like I used to hanging out as I
thought oh just giving them a break I
respect it let's you're Kobe percent get
some reps let the other guys get some
reps in there and now that it's kind of
followed into training camp I mean this
is the time where quarterbacks and wide
receivers have to get their rhythm and
have to get their timing and the
offensive line has to get the cadence
down maybe there's new people so this is
an important time for quarterbacks to
get on the field and practice so
whenever Andrew Luck wasn't practicing
it kind of took me back to when he was
sitting out and his shoulder was bad but
they weren't telling anybody how bad it
was or his liver or kidney or I think
you had like 45 injuries in one year
where they weren't telling anybody they
were just kind of sitting them out and
now that they're saying he's redoing
some of the rehab process I mean I think
all of Indianapolis is having nightmares
about what happened in the past and I
think the Indianapolis Colts can only go
as far as Andrew Luck leads them so I
think we're all banking on that calf
being healthy because everybody's saying
the goal is to get him back for week one
but I think we're missing some valuable
time here in training camp some
chemistry time with his wideouts and I
don't know what's going to happen but I
do know that the Indianapolis Colts fans
myself included our hope in that damn
calf comes back quickly
quicker than later and I hope it happens
but I know nothing did I know absolutely
nothing is Andrew Luck cooler than what
we think or dorkier nerdier than what we
think I you know he's a knight he's
nicer than what you think he's like the
nicest human I've ever talked to and I
think the footage from him getting
speared by another man and then
congratulating that person on the tackle
and all that stuff I think I think it's
very obvious he's a very nice guy but he
and I our conversations are tough man he
I've never read a book in my entire life
he runs a book club he's like Oprah I
mean he and I don't relate on much but
he is I don't think he's a dork or a
nerd I don't think he's cool I just
think he's been
Isis guy I've ever met and he's also the
smartest human I've ever met but having
a conversation with him you have to use
context clues to know what the hell the
words are that he's using in the census
I
it's like SAT word SAT word cat you're
that and I'm like I have no idea what
that means but I'm gonna go ahead and
smile laughs and just keep it moving and
hopefully we become friends someday
among the places you'll be able to see
or hear pat this fall the Pat McAfee
show will stream weekdays from 10 a.m.
until noon andhe's own and Westwood one
radio that debuts Monday September 9th
when you get married uh we haven't
settled on a date yet it is in the 20 20
years oh and forevers a long time Dan
you know happily ever after fairy tales
all that stuff it it took a long time
for me to get to this point I'm 32 now
I'm finally engaged and I'm excited for
it this wedding planning has not I mean
it's no joke Dan there's a lot of
questions that need to be answered and
all I know is I would like pizza and
fried chicken as the food options and
I'm not sure that's gonna get packed I'd
like to go to the reception I'd love to
have you there I think you're invited
though you should definitely come maybe
you should bring the Danette through the
reception all right guys you guys
interested in going to Mac if we don't
want to go to the wedding well I mean do
I have to go to the wedding if I if I'm
going to the reception do I have to go
to the wedding no oh I'm an American I
understand that that that is something
that people don't always want to be a
part of but I would assume that the
wedding is going to be entertaining as
well but I completely understand
I like the party as well so if you guys
were at the reception I think the entire
morale of the group would be lifted and
as soon as you all walked in the room I
like it I like it
yeah can you can you a place I said
Andrew look stable see I don't know if
Andrews gonna come
I mean we're glad to come to the magnet
mcafee nuptials a lovely centerpiece
there I have the over
the cocky special teamer ever getting
married this one's gonna be over in six
months day about haha can't find my flip
phone hey that is a top 5 Andrew Luck
impression right there they did it to
Andrew Luck we had Andrew Luck on the
phone a couple of years ago and I just
said you know what let's go for it and I
said Andrew we got a guy named Polly who
does an impersonation of you and I don't
know if he knew that you know we were
making fun of him it was just Pauly was
doing his Andrew Luck convert
impersonation did you sound exactly like
that research is you can't even spot
head in there too I mean it sounds like
they're all rookie the air guarantee
Paris Campbell I love that can I ask you
a question yes you can okay so when I
had you on my show I asked you about
what it's like to have a daily show for
so long and be at the top of the
mountain for so so long with you and the
day Annette's having you bet on yourself
you bet on your team whatever you
started it is eerily similar to what
we're doing you're an inspiration for
everything that my team and I are doing
I'm about to get into the daily radio
sports conversation world do you have
any suggestions or any tips or any
advice so I can survive past a week or
two without getting fired be curious and
have people around you who will keep you
honest and offer up suggestions because
there are times when somebody will say
what about this guess and I'll say no
and then somebody else will say no no
it'll be good for the show always do
what you think will be good for the show
not necessarily for you but for your
show but have topics don't be afraid to
have topics don't tell all your stories
pace yourself and if you're having
people who contribute on the show make
sure people who are listening know their
names that was one of the things that
when we first started I wanted to make
sure even though we were on TV
the you never leave out the people on
radio and I would always say you know
Dan it's just you know raise your hand
or you know make sure I acknowledge you
so the
audience knows who you are and that's
that was one of the things I did from
the outset
I wanted you on radio to never feel like
I excluded you and a lot of times TB
will do that so just a couple of
suggestions that that I would have going
into battle well I can't thank you
enough for that I'll keep that in mind
to remember at any time a legend speaks
of some advice I I tend to listen and
hope to listen I got a chance to learn
from Vinatieri in kicking balls world I
got a chance to now learn from Dan
Patrick's in the radio world into their
nets and I can't thank you enough I'm
very lucky dude and I'm excited to get
started bossman Thank You Pat good to
talk to you we appreciate your time
that's Pat McAfee he's starting a new
radio show in Westwood One and douzo for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]